I want to ask a few questions on each
one of these sure so let's let's talk
about divisiveness for a second so
there's no one who can make the case
that Donald Trump is not divisive of
course he's incredibly
divisive it's a given do you treat
Biden's rhetoric with the same level of
seriousness that you treat Trump's
rhetoric or I should probably put that
the other way around should we treat
Trump's rhetoric with the same level of
seriousness as Joe Biden or say Barack
Obama's rhetoric um I'm going to try to
be concise when answer
broadly speaking especially in studing
Israel Palestine and Ukraine Russia I
try not to take politicians at their
word CU sometimes they just say stuff to
say stuff I understand that but broadly
speaking I'm going to look at the
rhetoric and the actions and I am going
to grade them the same so yes I would
hold Biden and Trump to the same St
right so my feeling is and this is one
area where for clarification we're going
to have a division is that I of course
don't treat Trump's rhetoric in the same
way that I treat Biden's or Obama's he's
utterly uncalibrated he says whatever he
wants to at any given time and it
doesn't even match up with his policy
very often can I ask you like for our
head of state our chief executive
shouldn't rhetoric be arguably one of
the most important things that he does I
mean the answer would be yes and now
I've been given a choice between a
person who I think in calibrated ways
says things that are divisive and a
person who in uncalibrated ways says
things that are divisive and so the
evidence that Joe Biden is divisive is
every poll taken since essentially
August of of 2021 he he is by all
available metrics incredible divisive a
huge percentage of Americans are deeply
unhappy not only with his performance
but don't believe he's a uniter they
they're that that's just the reality and
that may just be a reflection I mean
honestly we may be putting too much on
Trump or Biden personally it may just be
that the American people themselves are
rhetorically divided because of social
media and social media can in fact be
assessible one thing that I would ask
you about that though is I agree
especially when you look at the
favorability but sometimes when I look
at these polls when you start to
disaggregate them by party I wonder if
it's actually is Biden historically
divisive or um I'm trying to think of a
really polite way to say this the people
that like Trump worship Trump I don't
know like one of the most preent things
that Trump could have probably ever said
was that I could kill someone on Fifth
Street and nobody would hold me
accountable so is it really that Biden
isly divisive or is it that every single
Trump supporter will always say that
Trump is great and always the reason I
would say that that Biden is in fact
historically divisive is because
Republicans felt much more strongly
about Barack Obama than Joe Biden
actually but they didn't feel as
strongly about Trump as they did about
like Romney or McCain right what way I
mean and the allegiance to Trump oh no
there's certainly more allegiance to
Trump than it is to romne or McCain
largely because Trump won in 2016 but
beyond that the the point that I'm
making is that if you're looking at the
stats in terms of divisiveness
Republicans always find the Democratic
president divisive the question is where
the rest of the country is and right now
there are a lot of Democrats who either
don't agree with Biden or you know find
him divisive there a lot of Independents
who find him divisive so when you're
when we're comparing these things I
don't think they're leagues apart in
terms of the divisive effects of what
they say right
and and I'm separating that off from
like the inherent content of what they
say because obviously what Trump says is
is more divisive just on like the raw
level I mean if he's insulting people as
opposed to Joe Biden doing Maga
Republicans like if I were to just if I
an alien come down from space and look
at these two statements I'd say this
one's more divisive than this one but
then there's the reality of being a
human being in the world and that is
everyone has baked Donald Trump into the
cake and Joe Biden again started off
with a patina of being non- divisive and
now has emerged as
divisive